yeah I know one welcome to this video
this is tactics trainer yeah chest tempo
let's do a couple of passwords going to
start and here we go
irritated isn't really where I'm this is
right here okay so um let's see what was
the next Moog f7 and we're looking for
black here okay let's see okay I've got
strong f3 pond at least it looks like
it's um some key point he takes it
however his rookie is unprotected this
is an interesting feature of the
position if I check on v1 King f2 only
moved to ship d4 check he cannot take on
f3 because rook f1 would pick up that
rock that looks like it might be a key
the key thing rupee one shaking f2
Bishop d4 check King g3 however I can
check on g1 okay the king of three again
loses you can go to f2 then and then
check on d4 and he has to take I'm sorry
I'm already on the forehead that stupid
rupee one shaking f2 bishop default
check King g3 check on g1 he goes to H 2
of course yes rook g2 check King H 1
looking check on g1 King edge 2 and then
f2
threatens the promotion and Bishop e5
with made am I missing something I mean
it looks rather simple check on b1 King
f2 Bishop g4 check takes on a 3s loosing
change III rook she one check
- H - look G to check back to h1 root G
1 check King f2 f2 he has a check on f5
but that doesn't really make much of a
difference I don't see why it's not
working is there any other idea I don't
really have a meeting net or anything I
mean something like Bishop f4 threatens
king D 43 but you will probably play
Bishop reform it looks totally straight
forward checking f2 Bishop g4 check I
don't see why not
okay now I basically have to check the
only move that check G to check g1 shock
f2 it does win it really does win this
is what was played out so that was a
simpler problem we see that 1987 this is
the problems rating by the way I'm now
on a on a premium account here or I'm
not sure what it's called here that the
go would account or something and I
could use a named enginetech technically
speaking but I never I never check
how it works here maybe if I press on
that hmm okay well I just play a couple
of positions that I solve a couple of
positions and I have to check for next
time yeah I'm glad that I got that one
in okay so let's get to the next problem
Wow white is taking on g6 hmm okay means
that if we take on c3 you go check our
look if we take on g6 with the pawn
that's night if form Queen g6 okay I
mean that it's not that bad for black
anyway but the question is is there some
kind of it's in something sorry about
the desk something really strong one
thing that I recognize is if I go to e7
that's probably strong actually rook to
e7 94 I take on e4 tix F takes before f3
threatens made on g2 he cannot go Queen
d2 I cover that and on g3 I play Queen
III check and this is the end yeah that
will win Rookie 7 looks very attractive
the knight to b5 is answered by rookie -
if he goes like rookie 791
I'm checking him on a1 King f2 and all
kinds of things probably rupee eight he
can always take h7 where I can just go
to age eight
Ruki seven looks strong it just looks
strong
let's say this right here that's right
move
yep so look everyone and now I can just
take the night and I'm a ruka anything
better
no no so it was it wasn't that tough I
am
I had the right idea right away
sometimes you really see the right idea
pretty quickly okay the next one
no wait loads a little bit okay Queen g5
and now we look for white hmm sorry it's
an equal material position and what
directly is some scanning them paradis
that there are some dependencies he and
blacks position de bishop on d5 is
covering that night on b3 which in turn
covers the rook on c5 so we have a
somewhat um yeah it's a bit of an
unstable position for for black IAM hmm
so what to do Queen on g5 is also a bit
should have got the coffee before I
video the Queen Han g5 is already a
little bit is this unprotected so hmm
what to do here
like it's not really threatening that
much see threatening something probably
not I mean why does reasonably well
coordinated
what about candidate moves them I mean
it's not so clear to me what what should
do one thing is that rook takes d5 comes
into consideration Rock d5 Rock d5 Queen
b3 is certainly nice but Rock d5 there
is Queen text e5 but I don't really see
the big point Knight c3 years a move
that might be interesting threat is just
to take on d5 and win that night
what is his reply to that if he moves
the bishop somewhere I'll take the night
anyway if he moves to the night which is
so so so much of a liability then I'm
taking the rook okay I don't really see
a reply to Knight c3 at the moment
fatigued d5 then next move he doesn't
have a tempo in the Queen he cannot
attack my queen and everything else is
nicely protected he has this Bishop only
five that's aiming at my king a little
bit but f3 g2 is safe
I wonder what what is what is flex reply
after Knight c3 I don't even see a
playable move actually
what is the move
hmm I'm overlooking something 93 looks
really simple says some kind of
counter-attack or you cannot move the
night I mean moving the ruckus not
helping
I see no reply and Terrell's I don't
even see a feasible different candidate
move I mean what else can i play
actually yep
so he took here so we just win the
exchange I guess or or not I said better
move than Queens III I don't think so
so we just have solved that one I mean
it really felt like there wasn't any
other move what I'm just wondering is is
rook a for now says something bad
happening to black can you check on c8
Bishop d3 check it doesn't seem that
dangerous if I take d5 you can go Queen
d5 I mean why does an exchange up but
it's the last to be one okay next one
gain some rating here already oh this is
a dramatic position but in fact it's
it's I'm a pawn up actually black as a
pawn up that's nice it's nice that it's
nice first thing that comes to mind is C
- C - Bishop C - whoopsie - and wins why
exactly is this not working it looks
very simple if he moves the Queen I
wonder
okay maybe Sifu let's see - Queen B 8
threatening bishop age seven
no but I have g6 for example and I don't
really see my 28 maybe so c2 Queen B aid
okay let's let's not be too too hasty
maybe there are alternatives
even though c2 looks good
definitely it does look good
C - Queen B 8 Catherine's made her
that's always annoying bishop h7 King h8
could have ain't made King Khan g6g 628
and differences seven rubgy one is
pretty strong thread I don't see how
this is not - okay Queen b8 I'm on the
right track the thing is now rook t1
stumbles into Bishop h7 f6 Bishop h7 is
the same story I don't really see
anything else then or is there something
after g6 that I'm not seeing g6 Queen f7
maybe g6 Queen b7 is what I'm trying to
say for Queen f7
she's six quid b7g six looks white just
look right but how do I protect it after
queen bee seven I really don't see a
move that's kind of weird
another idea is to just cover eight but
I'm not sure if that works by Queenie's
three or something
create is awkward then okay it's so
tricky Bishop d3 maybe yeah this is an
idea just taking that Bishop Bishop d3
yeah this is this Queen on the seventh
is kind of kind of annoying
hmm still tricky six Queen b7 I really
don't see anything there so I have to
avoid g6 amazingly enough I should t3
Queen b7 still how am i covering the
airport I don't see how amazing
I mean I can go Bishop now cannot Bishop
h5 use useless the blandness stuff okay
it's not a rook move and Bishop move
only their only ship that's only be 53
renamed g6 Queen d7 again I don't see
how to cover some amazingly enough so
Bishop d3
if he takes it and plays rook e8 and I
promote your queen am I actually winning
yeah I can take g5 was checked so I'm
winning so Bishop d3 still I don't see
exactly what I'm doing if he attacks
that have seven point then really should
be three Queen d7 sorry I don't see how
I'm winning there this is amazing
probably overlooking something really
simple g6
no she's six Queen be some I'm still not
convinced that there's nothing going on
there
kind of stuck with this yeah I don't
really see anything else and we should
be three and I don't see how I'm
defending the seventh rank then if he
goes Queen be seven again will be 7s
also it's a very annoying threat f6
Bishop h7 is still on mate but okay we
can go by process of elimination rook
moves don't work
the only Bishop move that it's not
ridiculous Bishop d3 c1 Queen runs into
mate Queen moves that protect it I mean
Queen a3 may be checking on h7 king of
aid does not really seem that that
dangerous but Queen a threesome is
amazingly slow it feels wrong again
twin p7 Queen a3 Queen b7
well become if I'm really going queen a3
Queen a3 have any trends to promote
maybe this is really right
Queen a3 Queen d7 still huh could be
something I'm totally stuck here I don't
see it
what am i doing in screen be served I
already saw this idea much much too late
86 is again run running into some kind
of meat is that yeah I wonder maybe
Queen a three years really that move for
that promotion and queen and roopd won
the defense for the moment you should
check King h8 neither seven to finish
them so queen a3 I'm going to play it
but I'm very unsure it is right
Wow okay was kind of process of
elimination but so and here is there
something better than Mook cheeks firmly
not weird sounds here
oh is it still some kind of trickery
going on I mean if it if it wants to see
a move there it's not completely random
then king h 7s maybe queen bee 1kg it
looks more logical anyway I really hope
I'm not screwing it up here
no I didn't Wow
I'll get 28 points their problems rate
it's really high yeah Queen is free it
looked like it looked like some some
other only move almost see - yeah I'm
going to check and now quit oops I hit
the wrong time there sorry guys yeah
here c2 was right and now Queen a3 I
didn't I didn't see any other move
really that that can can do the trick
he's threatening I mean if I go here for
example just a simple line I mated and
this is a huge threat really and if I go
g6 the thing is that then kind b7 is the
problem I cannot draw here yeah yeah
Queen takes the clean take their server
this is I cannot cover that so Queen a3
it turned out to be the solution tricky
okay let's do the next one I'm really
doing well that the mode G form wow that
looks like kind of last resort that
white is pulling those are often the
most problematic and you were like
winning maybe here with black yeah maybe
we're winning but we need to be precise
and terms here we know
how difficult that sometimes is to be
precise okie-dokie um NYCHA for Queen f7
a simple if I take with the pawn he has
bishops it would shake this looks
strange from the get-go I mean the move
that we have to look at with highest
priority is age three check anyway
because it's a check so age three this
is very likely the solution H recheck
King takes age three Queen age one check
look edge to Queen a3 checking edge for
in g4 has made so that's not going to
work he has to play King g3 then Queen
g1 check yeah if it goes to a three this
capture with the pawn and made I mean a
pre-check King takes Queen h1 check King
g3 Queen g1 check rook g2 Queen takes
III check goes back and then we can at
least grab that Bishop but that's g5 at
the end
hmm a bit tricky but it will win it will
probably win still okay ace recheck it's
the right move we can be I can be rather
sure about that yeah okay let's let's
play it Palace writings and now Queen h1
check we're taking with the pawn with
check if I take what the ponies got
kingly - I have no checks left necrosis
right well I can wait wait wait Queen f1
check is also interesting
Queen f1 check look G - FG 4 check King
H - doesn't seem so convincing Queen age
one shell King g3 Queen g1 check Butchie
- quintics III checker King edge - I can
take everything was check so okay I
guess that's right it's not right okay I
feel that I played this too quickly then
so what is winning let's check so so
queen f1 I really thought that this
would win rather easily I'm not quite
sure yet why it doesn't let's see what
the lines here what they show Queen g1
was was winning okay okay
I mean I understand the idea but why is
Queen h1 not working that would be
interesting to learn
it seems to be a draw queen age one
check check check
I had a completeness nation I was
thinking I can take this sorry I could
take you three but of course I cannot
there's a queen only eight ah what how
old are ya okay now this this was this
was stupid I got a little bit too
carried away after I got three free
positions right I guess HP was often the
second with slight trickier one yeah
quiz you won
I mean once you see it it kind of it is
kind of clear that it is strong what is
the relatively best defense what would
she - maybe from the teak queen here and
then Knight f5 check us even if possible
okay yeah so let's do one more
that was stupid that wasn't really
necessary at all - happy to screw up
okay
wow it's an endgame look g-force nothing
I'm sorry for the sounds okay quite
clearly I can play you okay have six
check and take on g6 okay f6 check
kingi seven rupees six rupees six kingi
6 h 4f v h3 f6 check King f8 e 6 h2
chance probably a drone well where's the
ticktick in this position it's there I
mean what exactly is our goal here I
mean a draw me probably have anyway I
wonder what the point is
King f8 maybe sections made oh no King
f8 is maybe interesting and tending book
f6 check and then March the pawn king of
8h through castex check King b76 check
it's rather quick that's a pretty poor
I mean they're not that many logical
moves there I mean I cannot go king h 7h
six and so on you will take the rook
rook moves on the seventh rank blunder
therefore pawn and look I have six
checking his seven doesn't really look
like it Nets much if anything there is
king evade
okay I'm gambling on that it is the
right move yeah IKEA so here take the
rook of course yeah and what's the only
way forward relief but who take
therefore it's not exactly the toughest
trial I was thinking is form six check
and then he six this is what what I was
seeing that the pawn now is really quick
and the rukia cannot help I mean drew
cannot help on the fourth rank so the
porn were probably really due to attach
down let's do one more just one more
okay well it looks like a dangerous
attack check on f8 somehow would be nice
it's just about his cupboard same ring
what is the porn down but it's not
really that important species are
protected he doesn't have so many loose
pieces the only thing that looks really
wrong is some it's that night only eight
maybe there is some kind of that's some
possibility to play on this idea
I don't even have an idea
I mean a move like 26 or so cannot be
terribly bad but it doesn't feel like
the solution to a tactical exercise
hmm I don't I have no idea Quinn takes
e5 I mean this is not a bad move but if
that is the solution then kind of not
understanding I don't really get it then
if that's right
hmm
an interesting factors is this overload
of the I mean overload is wrong but the
rukon d8 has to cover that night on yet
all the time something like hope d3 is a
move that rook takes d3 queen takes the
8th and wins but I don't really see how
to use this motif to our advantage we
loop these three years got rupees seven
or something like that
I don't see a huge point there
probably play Queen 65 and hope for the
best but that is not the solution I feel
like I'm not even seeing the proper
candidates
while the proper candidate move let's
say one one would move would be a
totally fine here the problem of the
slow moves let's say Queen f3 or so for
Queen evade it said well here Scott
Knight f6 and gets kind of coordinated
again
I don't I don't get it I really don't
get it
hmm any candidate moves Knight moves
make little sense we can go 94 but I'm
not really positive that it threatens
anything 93 yeah even if I was playable
the Queen is unprotected that he has
maybe there is something with the Queen
but I don't get it hmm remarkable
I need to talk very this small break
don't be irritated by the club jumping
forward ok I'm back I didn't use that
time to cheat
that's telefono idea I have absolutely
no idea
Wow I have no idea
I have no idea
where's the way where's the threat even
look a three Queen takes you five is
ridiculous sometimes at school if the
answer would be there is no tactic and
white really has to take one in five I
mean there are not that many moves that
make any sense
I cannot move with everyone rock rocky I
can actually but where exactly should I
go to look from c3 I mean he will take
c5 no more no matter water unless I go
to d3 route d3 is not such a stupid
looking move but I fail to see the real
point yeah maybe I'm threatening them to
take on d8 and then look f8 yeah like
that same route d3 he goes a5 which is
ridiculous just a non move and I can
take on d8 and then I can take only six
four four gave aid or give aid
immediately winning stuff but it doesn't
really feel like the solution
route d3 Knight f6
I hope t3 also might be just Queen f3
is really root is 7
maybe Queen f3 Knight f6
I don't I have really no idea completely
idle awesome
what about many Cree moves I don't even
see one with the threat
I mean Queen f3 yes but this knight f6
and this doesn't make any sense
Queen e5 is still not a bad move I
playing rook to e3 now but I'm pretty
impressed wrong it is right it is right
okay it still didn't really very force
to me but it was the only kind of move
that made sense with that in term with
this with black being somewhat
uncoordinated yeah and what what here
this is the as usual the issue the
second move Wow
don't think there's something
spectacular let's say 90 xe6
this just Roop takes the three antics
okay rook takes f6 immediately it's the
most obvious move anyway
f6 immediately G takes Queen g6 check
then group g7 fails you do to group the
828 Queen g7 496 so we will have a ton
of checks in any case rook f6 group 63
is this more interesting
Wow
six move 63 check on e8 check on the 8th
King age 7 Queen g6 check King G 890 63
and we have pizza wow that's working
okay really look at six roopd three
check on 8th King age 7 Queen g6 check
King G 893 really works on ya
so this looks good rook F 6 he has to
take with the Jeep on then Queen g7
check and after King f8 and kinoshita's
Queen f6 winning so rook F 6 does win
nice Queen g6 check or is it
no Queen g6 check is good now rook g7 I
can take da to take g7 for the
mm-hmm so this is actually the
computer's main line let's not be too
quick that it's really the right move
water huh look at the eight Queen D
eight Queen G 796 yeah well the whole
bow Wow
that is only rated 2000 something I
don't get it what's look these three
dead obvious I mean the stuff after that
it's not I mean it's doable but rook t3
is really the best move Wow I wasn't so
sure about how force this is Knight f6
okay i can really take and well I'm
threatening rook takes d8 Queen takes d8
crook FA check King takes F 896 winning
the Queen probably that threat is so
strong might be my beam wow that was
amazing the knight f6 that Juke f6 was
winning at the end was kind of it wasn't
so difficult
nice nice lines but not not super
difficult okay cool
let's end this video here and hope you
enjoyed it 45 minutes of techniques
calculation and me saying I have no idea
but I got most of them right I think I
made a screwed one up where when I had a
stupid idea that Queen age one check was
better in an earlier position but it did
well in the other ones okay I hope you
liked it thanks for watching